This episode of the podcast is the last
remaining podcasts from the Joe Rogan
questions.
Everything side five show,
we'll we do another episode of that show.
I have no idea.
It's up for debate.
It's in talks.
We've tried to figure out another way
to do it that doesn't involve driving to
weird places are flying in to meet a
bunch of shitheads who are aligned to us
about whether or not they've been abducted
by aliens or seen big foot or that
was the primary problem that we
had with that television show.
The big problem that I had with it was
I didn't want to do a show where we were
just running around debunking things.
I wanted to do a show where we were
talking to people that that brought up
questions that I thought was actually,
that I thought were actually fascinating,
that people that really had information
that stimulated your curiosity and I
really didn't find that too much.
We,
we've found that with the real subjects.
We found that with the
subjects like transhumanism,
when we talk to these people that
really were interested in pushing the
boundaries of technology,
um,
with those folks,
we really did have a
interesting conversations.
We really did cover subjects that
I thought were worthy of your time,
of your energy,
of your viewing and listening pleasure.
Um,
but far too often what
we dealt with was a,
a bunch of lost people that
were completely fixated on
ideas that were probably
nonsense and I didn't
want to do that anymore,
but I did enjoy doing know was
doing the podcast aspect of it.
I really did enjoy talking to Dunkin.
I really did enjoy hanging out with him
and having a good time just goofing on
life,
goofing on the situations
that we found ourselves in.
And one of the situations was when we
went to this place called skin Walker
ranch and skin Walker ranch.
Is this a place that's
out in the middle of Utah?
And uh,
we flew out there and met with
this questionable individual who,
uh,
I think it's safe to say is
at least mostly full of shit.
But the,
the,
the trip was still fun and
talking about it was fun and,
and just talking about it
was what I found to be the,
just the,
not just the most fun part
of doing the show for me,
but the most entertaining part of the
show was exploring these ideas with an
intelligent guy like Dunkin.
Um,
so whether or not the show moves on,
I will definitely continue to
do things like that with Dunkin.
So this is the last podcast and this
episode is brought to you by audible.
Audible is the leading provider of audio
entertainment for the worldwide web.
If you enjoy books,
uh,
and you haven't listened to books on tape,
you are doing yourself a disservice.
It's a fantastic way to
continue a book as well.
If you have the,
Amazon has this thing called the kindle
fire HD and they have an app called
whisper sync and would whisper sync does,
it allows you to read a book,
you read a book and you get to a certain
part of the book and you shut it off
and it syncs up with the audio recording
of that book that you can listen to in
your car or on your mobile phone or what
have you and you can listen to it while
you're in your car or while you're on
the train or while you're on a plane or
whatever you're doing.
It allows you to go back and forth between
reading the book and having someone
read the book to you.
Amazing,
amazing resource.
If you are curious about,
um,
audible,
audible.com forward slash Joe is where
you want to go and they will give you a
free audio book as well as 30
free days of audible service,
over 150,000 titles to choose from.
You will run out of time before you run
out of shit to listen to@audible.com it
is an amazing resource.
If you're looking for audio entertainment,
if you're looking for books,
lectures,
standup comedy,
um,
radio shows,
they have the opiate Anthony Radio show,
you can download a lot of other shows,
a fascinating conversations
with people throughout time.
They've recorded all sorts of really cool,
uh,
historical things as well as old
radio shows as well as great books,
fiction and nonfiction.
Audibles just a,
I love it.
It's just a tremendous,
tremendous resource.
So audible.com forward slash Joe,
go there and get a free audio.
Get a free audio book and 30
free days of audible service.
All right,
with that said,
this is the very last podcast
from the Joe Rogan questions.
Every time.
Logan Experience Joe
Rogan podcast all day.
Yeah.
Are we rolling?
We good?
Yup.
Yeah,
I'll smoke is in here.
All right.
Looking at this,
this is the fog of confusion.
That's what's in the air dock
and the fog of confusion.
Yeah.
The smoke of mystery.
Mm.
Um,
so we went to Skin Walker branch and uh,
we found a lot of crazy.
Yes.
Find a lot of crazy.
It was a,
an interesting place.
I'll tell you what,
Mike Miller,
the,
the gentleman that we talked to that,
uh,
lived with his cool dog
and had seen the orbs.
Yes.
That guy I enjoy talking to.
He seemed like a real to earth guy
that had no reason to lie to us.
He didn't seem like he had
any agenda and his story,
although sounds completely crazy while
he was saying it did not seem in any way
like he was being deceptive.
It seemed like he was
telling us a real account.
It's,
I know he was like,
I know it sounds crazy,
but it's what I saw and I believe him.
I mean,
I believe that he had this experience,
what it was,
who,
you know,
you would have to be there,
you'd have to see it.
And even then,
if you saw what he saw,
the way he explained it,
you wouldn't really know.
And I think that's a real problem with
any completely unique experience if you
had it.
And no one else had it.
What kind of a burden?
You know,
walking around,
like you've seen these rainbow colored
orbs that are the size of softballs and
they're flying around your house and
going through walls and your dog's looking
at them and you're shining lights on
them and they're avoiding the lights and
flying around.
What do you do?
It's over.
It's gone.
They leave.
You're back to just sit at home.
The TV still on,
your dog's still there and
you and all of a sudden,
you know you're forced with this decision,
like what you're faced with this decision.
What do you do?
You'd tell your friends about
this and he keep that to yourself.
What would you do if you saw a bunch
of crazy orbs flying or in your car and
then disappearing off into space and
then virtue and you know other than your
own strange memory of what just happened?
Life is exactly the same.
What do you do?
Do you tell people?
Yeah.
You tell people you've got a
responsibility to tell people.
You've got to be brave
enough to tell people,
because if you don't tell people,
then you're discrediting,
ah,
your species.
If there's some kind of brand new thing
that's happening that no one's observed
before and you see it,
you've got to have the guts to
get out there and tell people.
Sure.
They're just going to look at you like,
oh,
this is the typical dusty see meant Lang
desert recluse with a filthy dog who's
been huffing paint and
hallucinating warps.
That's all anyone's going to think.
That's the problem.
But I think that you must help
people because if you don't,
then no one's going to investigate it.
And if no one investigates it,
then these things will remain in the
land of the crazy instead of coming into
the light.
And if they come into the light,
think of what that would
do to all of society.
If we can prove that there's
hyper dimensional orbs
that traverse wormholes to
communicate with dusty old cowboys
in the middle of Mormon country.
Wow.
What a great way of putting it.
Yeah.
And,
and if they really are some unique thing
that we are experiencing for the first
time,
but we'll continue to show
itself and eventually become,
you know,
factual eventually be a part of,
I dunno what we consider reality,
you know,
you would be so pissed.
You're like,
I saw that too and I
didn't have the balls to speak out.
That's right.
And what if Marconi never spoke out
when he started discovering radio waves?
What if Darwin never spoke out when
he recognized that there was a process
called evolution that was
happening in the world?
What if Edison never
spoke out when he was,
uh,
stealing Tesla's ideas?
Yeah.
You know,
and it's really interesting because when
you stop and think about what you're
talking about,
this flying thing,
you know,
why is that any stranger than fish?
Why is it any stranger than some thing
that breeze water and does whatever it
wants in this three dimensional
world under the ocean,
right.
Why isn't any weirder than birds?
Yeah.
Why is that any weirder than,
I saw an eagle the other
day when I was in Seattle.
So on the eagle flying
knife faced death machine.
Yeah.
That was a dinosaur that survived.
It survived and figured out how to
fly and steel fish from the water.
Yeah.
If someone came out to me and said,
listen,
uh,
and I'd never seen an eagle,
and they're like,
which do you think Israel,
a floating orb that is alive and
follows you or a thing that evolved from
lizards that has a knife on its face
and flies through the sky killing fish.
Yeah.
It has like,
like like bone cutters.
Yes.
It's even sicker than a knife.
It's a pair of scissors.
It's a flying pair of scissors.
A giant scissors faced Munster
from 65 million years ago.
Yeah.
That carries away your cat,
your Chihuahua and survived a giant
five mile wide chunk of stone and metal.
It's slammed into the earth and killed
just about everything except these
country flying lizards.
Yes,
exactly.
And also look,
go down under the ocean,
go down into the deep,
deep parts of the ocean where you see
those creepy glowing Goblin things that
just live down there.
Absolutely.
There's things that are live.
There's self luminescent or we'll
bio luminescent like they glow.
They make light underneath the water.
How crazy is that?
Why is that any crazier than,
why is a flying orb crazy than that?
It's really not.
Especially when you
consider what that orb did.
It's not like that orb stole his cat and
flew away within eight it on top of a
rock like an eagle would write.
An Eagle would steal your cat,
man.
No problem.
Eagle has no problem.
You leave a baby alone with an ego.
Watch what happens.
Sure.
It'll be crazy.
Yeah,
it's crazy man.
And,
and but here's the difference.
Or if it's just fly around
the baby and take off,
nobody gets hurt.
We don't know.
Maybe the orbs plant seeds in the baby.
The thought of the baby change the way
the mind works and the ties the baby.
Maybe the orbs drive the baby.
Insane.
But we,
the,
the difference of course is that
there's a million pictures of eagles.
There's very few pictures of orbs.
There's a million pictures of
undersea death goblins that glow.
No pictures of Ufo.
So there's photos of orbs.
There's photos that people put
online that they claim to be orbs.
The problem is they're very
much like our guide in,
in Utah,
the the,
you know,
I don't know me,
maybe everything he said was
a hundred percent factual,
but it was so crazy to hear someone
who says they've seen big foot,
they've seen orbs and bulletproof Wolfe's.
They've seen all these things themselves
and they're telling you it's just a
spot.
This is the squeezebox.
Maybe he's telling the truth
but it's so fantastical.
And that is the sort of the same thing
that comes along with all of these,
all of these tales,
whether it's orbs or wolves or,
or any of the crazy things that we
were told that these people saw.
If they are real,
you're dealing with some crazy,
unique experience that really I commend
you for coming out and talking about it.
Cause I might keep my mouth shut.
I probably wouldn't,
I'm pretty stupid.
I would definitely talk about it.
If I saw something cool,
I would try I or am I talking about it?
I would talk about it,
but some people didn't want to talk to us.
And I could understand that first couple
that we meant that we were supposed to
talk and then the day of shooting
they got cold feet and they were like,
you know what?
We don't even want to talk about this.
It's like the last thing I want to do
is be that person on TV talking about
something duddy and they're like,
no,
no.
We're not not doing it.
Like they just were done with it.
They thought about it,
probably kept him up all night,
wisely cell.
But uh,
Mike didn't give a fuck.
You know what man?
Yeah.
He didn't give a fuck.
It didn't bother him at all.
And he told it to us,
just matter of fact,
and I was with them every step of the way.
I believe that guy was
telling us at true encounter.
Oh,
I don't know what it was.
I don't know what made me,
who knows?
He might have had like a misfiring of
like several key elements of his brain.
Sure.
And they might start producing
hallucinations in front of them.
Who knows how much whiskey he drank
right before he saw these orbs.
Yeah.
Who knows?
Who knows what cold medicines.
He mixed up a lot.
Who knows?
But the bottom line is this guy,
when he was telling us about this,
I believed them and if you and
I had just gotten to see it,
man,
what a world changing event that would be,
but that seems to be a part of the
narrative of all this really crazy
fantastical stuff.
It's like if you could
be there and see it,
boy would just change the world.
But when you go look in,
nobody finds shit ever,
ever,
ever.
It doesn't matter if you're
looking for big foot,
if you're looking for Ufo woes,
if you're trying to find
the loch ness monster,
you never fine shit.
People finance these giant missions.
They take these
[inaudible] radar machines,
troll the lock in Scotland every couple
of years they spend so much money
looking for something that's
probably never been there.
But that's,
that's what we do.
That's what human beings do is we try
to expand our understanding of the
universe and part of that means
investigating claims of bizarre
creatures and aliens and Ufos.
We have to investigate it,
but the difference between science and
these people is science is comfortable
with what they call a null hypothesis.
They're comfortable coming back with
no results and saying it's not there.
The thing that these people
don't seem capable of,
or at least the guy who had seen the
bulletproof wolf and big foot and
everything is he saw everything.
He hit the supernatural lottery.
He saw big foot the first
night he went looking.
Yeah.
The first night,
there are people up there,
there are people up there for years,
slowly going crazy under the moon.
This guy goes out one night,
bigfoot shows up,
did some calls that he
learned from watching TV,
TV,
bigfoot show.
So you know,
man,
the problem is that those
people are under super lucky.
Their problem is they're just lucky.
Super Lucky.
She's,
he's a magnet for paranormal activity.
Yeah,
that's,
that's definitely what it is.
That's what he is.
He's a magnet for the paranormal.
I just think that he is.
That would be hilarious if it was.
It was just like this guy who is just,
you know,
not the most charismatic guy,
doesn't seem like you know
any different than you or I,
but yet the aliens just decided,
this is our guy.
This is why he's our go to dude.
Don't be an alcoholic.
Well,
maybe this is why don't live around
really stupid people because maybe the
aliens landed in his town and
everybody else is like barely a monkey.
They're just apes.
Apes with a language and him in his town,
he's the dawn of the town,
like he's the smartest guy for miles.
It's a rough town.
They'd looked around and they said,
you know what?
This is our guy.
You know,
they maybe they didn't do a really good,
accurate assessment of the
entire population and find
out who's the smartest guy
here.
Okay,
let's go talk to Neil degrasse Tyson.
He seems to be totally on the ball.
He seems like the best guy
we could communicate with.
No,
they showed up in some meth adult
shit hole of a town and it's fucking
tumbleweeds flying by and people shooting
up in the corners and it's just a mess
everywhere you look.
Gambling addicts are stealing money and
everyone's on some fucking form crank
and uh,
they found all Ryan Ryan was washing his
truck and listen to like conservative
talk radio.
We seem to stock seems like a
normal guy and they're like,
we found the guy.
This is the best America has to offer.
They just didn't.
They look at us like we're so stupid.
Like the way we look at Champs,
I mean it takes a long time
studying chimps for you,
figuring out what's the
bad motherfucker champ,
what's the one champ that figured out
how to take the stick and widdle the end
of it so he can get the ants easier?
You know what,
what does the one chimp that figured
out how to mimic human behavior and do
certain things,
it takes a long time to find that guy.
So if there's so much more advanced
than us than we are from champs,
if it's like that much of a leap,
they probably look at these idiots.
They probably look at it,
this is a sea of idiots
or I find this one idiot
that's not eating his own poop.
Oh let's grab that guy and scoop him up
and let's show him everything was show
him everything and see if he can,
uh,
you know,
perhaps a help us enlighten
this crazy species.
Man,
you're,
I think you're right.
Cause in by being,
by the way,
if I'm studying champs,
I'm going to pick the crazy one
because it's more interesting.
Who are you going to
take the normal champs?
You're going to take the chimp.
It's off by himself,
by a tree drinking many vodkas
and staring into the sun,
making weird noises to
summon a mythical creature.
I get that day's sitting an Indian casino
way drunker than any buddy should be
and be allowed to walk on
their own screaming expletives
cause they lost all the
money they've ever made
ever on a game of chance.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's the chimp you want to study.
Maybe aliens don't believe in crazy
people and they try to prove the crazy
people exist by finding them and taking
pictures of them may be aliens are smart
enough to avoid credible people.
Then they figured the best way to get
the information they need is to find
someone who already has a pension
for stretching the truth and a duck.
That motherfucker,
and then when you're done with them,
go,
go tell your friends,
tell everyone,
go tell your friends.
That's what they say.
They put them on the
front door and they go,
go ahead.
Go tell your friends,
dude.
And he's just sitting there like,
fuck.
Hey,
you dropped your tequila bottle.
Don't forget your Tequila when you leave.
Oh,
don't worry.
You've got plenty of meth in your urine.
You're going to come up clean.
Get outta here,
dude.
So the guy goes to the police
department and tells a story,
pisses in a cop,
and they go,
get the fuck outta here.
What's in here?
This can get me how I could drink
this and get high for a month.
Feed it.
Get out of here.
Scrammed storyteller.
It's really smart.
It's genius.
It's a genius thing to do.
It's true.
The last thing you want to
do is have duct some logical.
Yeah,
Obama have.
Obama feels compelled to tell the
world and they actually listen.
People alter their behavior.
Start looking for Ufo is put on
special glasses like and they live.
Remember that movie?
Rowdy Roddy Piper,
John Carpenter at school.
No one's gonna believe Obama.
How dare you?
No one believes it when he
talks about anything alien.
Maybe that would be perfect.
That will be the ultimate cover.
Come straight to Obama and that's
the one thing they'd be like,
everybody's like,
you know what,
this guy,
we got to get them out of office.
Like everybody's fine with drones.
Everybody's fine with
paying off the banks.
Everybody's fine with arresting
people for medical marijuana.
Everybody's fine with everything,
but he says he saw a Ufo.
This motherfucker goods,
get him out of here.
God,
that'd be fun to be an alien.
Wouldn't are.
You get to get to suck anybody into your
ship and do anything you want to them.
No one can call the police.
Just drop them off.
Go,
go tell your friends.
Yeah.
Tell her to shreds.
By the way,
we're invisible to everybody,
but you know,
I mean you don't think that
they can make you invisible.
I mean,
it seems to me that if you can
come here from another planet,
pretty much you do anything.
Whatever you can manipulate in our world.
You,
you know,
you might
be a bulletproof wolf.
Maybe that's like the best way to show up.
Sure.
See a wolf that you can go ahead,
shoot me.
You pretend that they hurt
you and then you fly away.
He turned into mist and you vanish.
Why don't we,
why would we assume that they're
limited in their ability to exist in,
in matter the way we are just
contained by this biological prison.
Yeah.
Maybe they can be missed shipment.
Maybe they can do it.
Maybe they just appear out of nowhere.
I mean,
they don't get in big stupid ships
like we do and fly through the air.
Maybe they're like,
oh my God,
they're still doing that.
Do you know,
do you can just become mist and
appear as like a wolf or something?
Yes.
Maybe they do that.
I mean,
why not?
Wouldn't you know,
that's,
listen,
if,
now this is a big if,
but one of the gentlemen that I talked to,
um,
to real,
what's his first name?
Rich Terrile.
One of the gentleman that I talked to,
this guy,
rich to real.
It's from the JPL labs.
All right.
This guy's super smart.
Jpl Lamb.
I don't know what they do there,
but it's very important.
Very important rocket sciency type stuff.
Yeah.
Well we were talking about simulation
theory and one of the things brought up
about simulation theory was if you don't
know that you're in a simulation and as
you're in that simulation you
create another simulation.
Like what did that sort of mimic the
fractal behavior that the whole universe
seems to exist or seems to,
seems to show that exists everywhere.
Everywhere you look,
whether it's the FIBONACCI sequence,
the way it applied self
to sunflower seeds,
or just the fact that you go into the
atoms themselves and there's so much space
there.
Yes.
It's almost like the,
uh,
like the universe.
And if that's the case and if what we're
looking at is just a representation of
an artificially created world and
inside that artificially created world,
we're working feverishly to
create another artificial world.
If that's the case,
then maybe alien life is just simply
someone who decides to present itself as
that inside the simulation.
I mean,
if we really are a completely
in a world of ones and Zeros,
we may really be limited by our
imagination more than we're limited by
possibilities.
We just seem to only be capable of
imagining things that someone has already
documented,
whether it's a tiger or
a shark or a tornado,
it's these things are documented,
so we'll accept them.
But maybe if it's a simulation,
there's some shit out there that we
just haven't seen in the game yet.
Yeah,
there's some new levels
to the movie where you,
you know,
you pass this area and all of a sudden
you're in a magic land and bulletproof
walls exist and turn out a mist and they
land on your porch and they look at you
and you shoot him in.
They vanish.
I mean,
the uh,
ability to have wireless communication
existed when people were beating each
other's heads and with rocks and
worshiping golden the same time
always been there.
It's just they hadn't discovered it yet.
So it's true.
No doubt there's some amazing
technology or some amazing,
uh,
law in the universe that we haven't
quite discovered yet that eventually we
will,
that will be as disruptive to society is
every other invention or discovery like
that.
But these discoveries are not made
generally by people who stink of Jen.
Okay.
And who go wandering
drunk through the desert,
staring up into space.
These discoveries are made by people
who have an inclination and impulse and
I've studied a lot of science and know
the process that you can uncover these
laws,
which is why it's so important to
approach these things from a scientific
perspective because otherwise you
end up with an unprovable thing.
Maybe you saw something,
but the fact that you're not approaching
it scientifically immediately
discredits you.
You said something that was very
important and I want to reassert it.
You said that the ability to
communicate wirelessly always existed.
We just hadn't figured it out yet.
Yes,
but it always existed just we didn't
have the technology to unearth it.
That's such an important point that
you made and I don't think people could
really wrap their head around that.
It's really hard to,
we can sort of see the future
like a little bit in the future,
like we think about it,
but whenever we've tried to guess,
we're always so off,
you know?
Like do you ever watch space?
1999 now.
I was a great show.
It was a great show,
but it was 14 years ago supposedly.
I mean the show is made in the 70s
or the eighties or something like,
I think it was the 70s and it was supposed
to be about the future and in 1999
like space 1999 this is going to be crazy.
We're just going to be living in the
galaxy in 1999 like there's so off.
Everybody's always off.
But you know what?
They never saw on space down at 99 Google.
Right.
They didn't have all the answers.
They didn't know where they were going.
They couldn't,
they didn't have navigation systems.
They didn't have any of that shit.
They didn't have cell phones.
Okay.
They talked to each other.
It was like a walkie
talkie type situation,
you know,
like in the and the enterprise Kirk out.
No,
nobody saw what we have right now.
That is completely insane.
That's right.
I mean,
we literally have the power of immortals.
If we lived a thousand years ago,
we would be some strange
freak existence that,
you know,
people had never seen a
guy with a cell phone,
never seen a guy in a car
pull up with a cell phone,
never see a guy step out with sunglasses
on and have a machine gun in his hand.
All the things that we have
today that seemed like an insane,
impossible,
unimaginable things a thousand years ago.
They're totally,
completely 100% common.
Yeah.
You take,
you pluck someone from a thousand years
ago and drop them into any city in the
world and they might go crazy
or pluck someone from a thousand years
the future and who knows what kind of
shape you can take.
Right?
Who knows what,
what,
you know,
whether or not you,
you can even tell a port consciousness
into other objects and ideas.
We have no idea what's
going to be possible.
And once they start figuring out a way to,
to put technology deeper and deeper
into our lives or we ever become part
technology ourselves.
Some form of Cyborg.
Yeah.
Anything is fucking
possible when that happen.
That's right.
Anything's possible.
And it's the people who have the most
open minds that end up making the
discoveries that transform history.
So that's why it's important for people
to not be afraid to explore these
things.
It's just the way you explore it.
It's gotta be precise,
right?
Because if you aren't precise,
then you end up in a lot of trouble.
I mean,
it's best case you end up
wandering through the desert.
Maybe you fall into an ants nest cause
you're a little too drunk and you know,
you go home with some stinks.
Worst case,
you've got a little bit more
charisma than that Fella had,
you know?
And then you start telling other people
like you that you can communicate with
bigfoot and they all say what?
Really?
Yeah,
I communicate with big foot and he
told me that I should start a church.
And the next thing you know,
you've got someone who's started a
new religion about worshiping bigfoot,
surrounded by equally nutty people who
have no interest in proving anything at
all.
And then that's how religions start.
And then you know what
inevitably happens next?
The person says that big foot came to
them and a dream and said that they have
to have sex with your wife.
I don't know why he wants me to do that,
but he wants me to do that.
He wants me to do that.
Or the bulletproof wolf will come
and that's how religion started.
That's how it starts,
man.
And that's why it's dangerous.
And that's why people like that have to
be held to actual scientific principles.
Because if they're not,
then they can cause a lot of problems.
That's awesome.
Why were we talked about before?
It's important to hang out
with people that are smart.
If you hang out with a
bunch of dumb people,
especially if you're that guy,
if you can just tell
them things like that,
like you met a bulletproof wolf and like,
Whoa,
where's the wolf?
You tell that guy anyway.
You'd start making things up just to
keep yourself entertained because you're,
you're dealing with uh,
an ape.
You know your friends and ape.
Right and completely stupid.
There's people out there
that'll just like that.
Once you have a person near you who
believes that you saw a bulletproof messed
wolf,
you can definitely get them
to give you a blow job.
Easy,
easy,
easy.
You could tell them that the aliens
told them that you have to give them a
blowjob or everyone will die.
Yeah.
Baby's first.
Yeah,
you got to do it.
Get up there.
I don't want to,
by the way,
I don't want you to give me a blowjob.
This hurts.
Last thing I want,
but if you don't,
all the babies die.
Yeah.
His thing eats babies and it's
going to come from a wormhole.
Alright.
Where am are great too,
because you don't have
to show a launch area.
You don't have to like
pretend that there's like a
secret spot where you got to
go to.
You know when it's,
when it's a wormhole with something as
simple as a worm hall just sits there.
It's not whatever.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
What's round?
Every time you move you
put it on the unsightly me.
This
on the cable?
Yeah.
Every time we move the cable connecting.
Oh,
okay.
Here I'll put it in the front.
Thank you.
No problem.
Okay.
Babies and monsters.
Do you want to talk?
Where was I?
You were talking
babies
baby.
Yeah.
You were saying?
You were saying that you convince these
people that the bulletproof wolf eats
babies if they don't give you blowjobs.
Yeah,
it's not likely,
but it probably could happen.
It's not likely.
I mean God,
look at religion.
Look at religion.
I mean I was just telling
you about this on the,
I don't know if I was just telling
you about this on the phone,
but Joseph Smith.
Yeah.
What?
Tell girls that they had to marry
him or they would be damned to hell.
Now what's the difference?
It's,
see that's the problem.
If someone had gone to him and said,
look,
you've got to prove this thing telling
you that you can have sex with my
daughter before you have sex with her.
I want some proof.
Measure it.
Show me the tablets I want is,
I want to know who this thing is.
It's telling you that you to stick
your penis and my daughter religiously,
you know,
you have to hold people accountable for
stuff like that or they will hum pew.
That's the inevitable result of this man.
The slippery slope ends with you laying
back in the desert with some guys
sitting on your face like a saddle
is lumping your mouth kind of
doesn't roll.
Kind of all go back to what we discovered
when we went looking for big foot.
It's really,
it's kind of,
there's a similar thing going on because
it's all people that are getting very
little physical affection,
you know?
And this is why they have the free
time to be out there looking for Ufo.
Yeah.
It's like nobody wants to fuck them.
And so because of that
you develop this deficit.
This is a desperate need for mystery.
Desperate need to somehow another
validate the emptiness that is regular,
normal life with big foot or with
Ufo shows or with fill in the blank.
What or whatever crazy
thing you blink Jervis,
Jersey Devil,
what do you believe in?
Loch ness,
monster,
UFO abduction.
Well,
whatever it is,
reputation,
all of it.
Channeling,
so she's a channel or in a healer.
Oh really?
It's very frightening of
you cause that's what you,
it's like from a Freudian perspective,
what you're saying is that
they're oppressed sex drive
manifests in these kind
of the hallucinations or wish fulfillment,
illusions,
delusions and you know also I think it
puts you in a community of people that
are also idiots are more
likely to hump here because?
Because I like more gullible.
Yeah and easier to have sex with because
they're gullible because they lack
critical thinking skills and
you can tell them crazy stories.
They're much more likely
to have sex with you.
It's not a new idea.
It's not a bad idea.
Look if we know that the
primary motivation for most
males 18 to 34 or whatever
the hell it is,
demo is spreading,
spreading,
and spreading sexuality,
getting,
getting into position to
have as much sex as possible,
as often as possible with people
that are as pretty as possible.
We all agree to that.
We know that it's the motivation behind
flashy cars and jewelry and $50,000
watches.
If there's only men on the planet.
Do you think they sell
any $50,000 watches?
No.
No one would buy one.
We wouldn't give a fuck.
No one's going to have sex with you.
You know,
unless you're gay,
you wouldn't buy that watch.
Okay?
But if you factor in all the reasons
why people do all the things they do,
buy the biggest house where the flat,
fanciest clothes,
he's always sharp.
What?
He's,
they're setting themselves up to be a
primary sexual candidate and when that no
longer applies,
where's your motivation for life?
Where's your motivation
to get up in the morning?
What do you,
what are you doing?
What's going on in there?
There's no more libido and you're not
even remotely attractive so you can either
scrape up enough money doing what
you do really good and pay for it,
which always feels gross.
I'm sure never done it.
Never.
Well me.
You know what I'm saying?
Even if I did what I'm
saying is it would be sad.
It was sad to be some 60 year old dude
who worked his whole life to put together
a meager bank roll and every couple of
months he blows some of it on an escort
and in between that he's looking
for Ufo was to stay out there too.
We've got,
we were basically locked down.
We've got a hundred percent proof now.
What we got here is a smoking gun.
This guy actually told us
and signed an affidavit.
We got the gun,
we got the smoking gun.
That's right here.
Look,
it's been done.
If you don't believe in Ufo Ufos,
you're crazy.
Okay,
cause we got it all.
We've got it here.
We got it now because
he's a very exciting time.
Yeah,
they released this information
is going to be no denying.
We've got top level people from all
areas of the government who come out with
amazing stories.
And once you hear those stories
and it will be undeniable,
and then they give themselves just like
sense of excitement along with reciting
this stuff and talking about this stuff.
These mysteries are getting young covered,
but they never tell him to have her do.
It's a mating dance.
It's part of the mating dance.
It's like a tail.
They pop up the book,
big foot tail feather,
pop up the Ufo tail feather at
you do that after a few drinks,
you know,
and it kind of dark bar you'd say like,
look,
I don't tell a lot of people,
but I had an incredible encounter
in the desert a few weeks ago.
And uh,
look,
I,
I probably shouldn't tell you know what,
what happened?
Um,
well first it started off as a mist.
You know,
you're at,
it turned into a wolf and
then you started a little,
maybe a little crying,
like you're a little upset about it.
Next thing you know,
you're back in the days in enjoying a
nice roll in the Hay with somebody that
you've probably drugged.
You know what's weird about the
people that tell these stories to,
this is one thing that I've been noticing.
There's people that will tell
these stories and they'll
tell it to you in a way
where you feel like they're
recounting a memory.
You know,
like Mike Miller,
that's his name,
right?
Like know,
like Mike Miller,
he fell to me that he
was recounting a memory,
but other people that we talk to just
we're saying a bunch of words in order.
It's like it was complete.
There's a complete flatness to the way
they described these encounters that
doesn't register with you at all.
Like did talk to you.
They're like,
well,
I went into the woods and we started
doing these sacred howl and uh,
all of a sudden we saw the,
um,
the pyramid in the sky opened up and a
from it came this alien craft and you're
just hearing a bunch of words.
You don't,
there's,
there's nothing connected to this person
is there's nothing connecting them with
that story.
And there's nothing connecting
you with that story.
They're not trying to connect you with
that story to trying to say the words in
order that they think would make sense
if you were talking about a crazy
incident that happened,
but it was clearly an incident
that didn't really happen to them.
And there's a sense that
we all have for that.
It's not bulletproof.
It's not,
it's not 100% but this is a sense that
you have when someone's telling you a
story where you know they're full of shit.
Yes.
And uh,
that's a weird thing.
It's a weird thing to be in front of
people when you know they're not telling
you the truth,
but we all know what it's like.
W We,
it's not that people can't trick us.
People certainly can trick you,
but when you know someone's full of Shit,
you really do know they're full of shit.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not 100% it doesn't
work with everyone.
And there are people that are sociopaths.
They are people that are
really good at lying.
There are people that are very charismatic
and can con people that can steal
your money then yes.
Bill,
you either they're experts at lying.
Sure.
Actors.
I mean what,
what are,
what does being an actor is being a liar?
Yeah.
You know,
I'm not saying that they would
lose it in their personal life,
but Daniel Day Lewis would be the greatest
fucking liar and the history of the
world's thinking about how good
that guy will be at lying to you.
You know,
did you spill the milk and he comes down
and he looks like he has an eat in a
week.
He's fucking hobbling and yeah,
cause it shits his pants
while he's talking to you.
You know,
that guy would,
you'd be like,
oh for sure.
That guy didn't spell them out for lie.
He's telling me the truth.
He's crying as poor guy has like
he's got cerebral palsy or something.
Yeah.
Let me take him to the bathroom and clean
him up and he punches you in the face
and rapes you.
You know why?
Cause he was faking it the whole time.
He just wanted to get you to where
you were alone with them in a bathroom
washing his ass,
cause he can't wash it himself
and then he just beats the shit
we doing.
This is like our erotic Daniel Day,
Lewis and fiction.
I don't even know what it is.
Like you didn't even know
I'm doing or you went
down the road.
How did he end up in your house?
We started talking.
I just made all that up.
But that's,
that's the universe
giving me a little gift.
It's a gift of,
it's called creativity.
I love the idea and over comes from,
it's just a gift.
I love the,
this is my,
I love the idea of like
someone spilled milk.
Daniel Day Lewis comes in,
you know,
did you spill the milk?
He's like,
no,
suddenly you're washing his asshole.
He shits all over himself cause
he's scared because he's scared him.
He pretends that he's really
sick and feeble and you,
you yelled at him.
So he just defecates all over himself.
He's crying but he can't wash himself.
And that's one of the reasons,
I mean snots coming out of his nose,
he's weeping.
He can't even breathe.
He's doing it so well.
You feel terrible and you're like,
we'll clean you up on it.
We'll clean you up.
So as you're cleaning,
he just beats the shit out
of you on fucks your mouth.
He holds you down,
just punches you in the face until you're
unconscious and you know you wake up
because you can't breathe out of your
mouth because it's filled with caulk.
Try to get some air through your nose.
What?
Daniel Day Lewis,
just fucking your mouth.
Why?
Because he's an awesome liar.
He tricked you.
He got you a bitch again.
And I think that that,
I think that's one of the most important
things a person can talk about.
Points that I think that's the important
point is that there is a slippery slope
when you're around a wire that we'll
end with that liars cock in their math.
But I think there's this,
there's a real slippery
slope with human beings.
If you are around someone who's trying
to be deceptive in order to profit on
something or trick you into something,
someone who gets really good at
figuring out how to pretend that they're
something they're not,
or they seen something they haven't
just in order to get something from you,
whether it's your attention
or whether it's your money.
There's a weird thing
where people realize like,
oh,
I don't have to tell the truth.
What I have to do is just make up a
good story that allows me to get into a
situation or I'm on TV
telling this story yet.
And so that's what they do.
They just sort of like lumped together
this idea in their head and maybe they
rehearse it,
maybe they wing it,
and in that case you just keep asking
him about it over and over again over a
long period of time.
And they slowly start.
It's twisting that story around because
they don't remember what the hell they
told you.
Listen,
there's so much money in it,
man.
I show much money if bills.
Look at the Vatican.
I mean,
my God,
the moment you can convince people that
you're in contact with a thing you can't
take pictures of or prove
and they believe you,
you are loaded.
You can get so rich and religion has
shown this again and again and again.
I mean these people take
it to the nth degree.
There are these,
you know,
the people we ran into in the desert,
the guy thinks he saw a wolf that
turns into mist and big foot.
If we drive 10 miles in any
direction and go to a church,
I can sit you down with a person who
thinks that there is living in the sky
and invisible man that is going
to destroy all of humanity.
Uh,
it's all going to happen in Israel.
Now that's within 15 miles
in the difference between
the guy wandering drunk in
the desert and the person wearing the
funny priest outfit is the priest has
people who give him money every
week to listen to that story.
They drop it in the,
they drop it in the collections plate and
send that thing around and just listen
to that story again and again.
The man in the sky forgives
you sins and he comes down,
he comes down.
If we're all good and ready,
he'll come down and take us
away from this terrible planet.
No more bulletproof Wolfe's,
no more big foot's just
peace and love forever.
That's a gigantic business right now.
Those people don't even have to pay taxes.
There's such good liars.
Did they have convinced the United
States government to not take taxes from
their multibillion dollar businesses?
Wow.
That's amazing.
And that's the end of the thing.
So they're the same thing.
They're,
they're on the spectrum.
They're the successful version of it.
The non successful version is the guy
who stinks of Gen wandering through the
forest pointing at mud puddles and
telling you it's big foot footprint.
The successful version of it is the guy
wearing robes and gold and sitting in a
golden throne and telling the
planet that they shouldn't,
where birth control.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
Totally makes sense.
These guys,
um,
it's almost like they
can't help themselves.
Have you noticed that?
It's almost like no matter
what you talk about,
they just have a story.
It just comes out.
All right.
Well,
the ones that are telling
like a lot of stories,
that's why you know,
it's always,
they don't just see one thing.
Oh,
they've seen chew Bekaa Bros,
they've seen nessie.
They were on vacation in Scotland.
We saw nessie triple dog,
dare you.
They've seen everything.
They can't even help themselves.
Oh No,
thank you.
Thank you.
Want to tell you a state
want to lie to you?
Well,
it's,
you know,
I think there's an evolutionary advantage
to it and I think that the moment you
begin to realize if you're
okay with telling lies,
you start making tons of money and
people will start having sex with you,
then you could see how there's like a
profound evolutionary advantage to being a
liar.
And the ultimate liar is the
liar believes that himself,
who's told himself the story so
much that he started seeing it.
There's a huge evolutionary
advantage to this sort of thing.
So I,
I,
that all being said,
the real problem here is that
in this sea of horny liars,
there's a few people
who've seen something real.
You think?
Yes.
Okay.
If you had to put all your
eggs in a basket and pick D,
I'm going to give you three subjects,
ghosts,
big foot and aliens.
Okay.
What are those?
Which one of those do you think that
anybody has ever seen a re had a real
experience,
a real experience or actually
something actually happened?
I think people have seen hyper dimensional
entities,
uh,
that could be classified
as ghosts or aliens.
Do you think that they've
seen these while sober?
No.
That's the problem though,
isn't it?
There's a variety of chemicals that
radically affect the way you see reality.
And so the real problem is do we just
set as a standard the level of chemicals
that exists in a normal human
being without any outside help?
And we'll call that like the baseline.
Yeah.
Do we accept that or tweaked out
of their Gourd on magic mushrooms?
Because that's also a state
of consciousness a human
can achieve if they consume
the right foods.
I mean that it really
is what your experience.
So if you under that situation have a
real honest to goodness alien encounter
where you exchange information and
you come out of it a better person,
like in enlightened by the
face of this experience,
even if it didn't really happen,
it still happened in your mind.
That's right.
It's still something you experienced.
So that could be an entity.
Well
this is why we need a NASA
for psychedelics because
that's when people are
experiencing these,
these experiencing these things.
Let's explore it.
And I think you know a lot of people,
and I,
you know,
I've done this myself.
When someone tells you a crazy story of
like what are you high like that does
credits the person.
But what if the mind is an antenna and
what of certain chemicals allow you to
tune in to other frequencies
that exist around us at all time.
And everyone knows that we're surrounded
right now by all kinds of invisible
frequencies,
ultraviolet light,
radio waves,
wireless signals.
We are in an ocean of information washing
around is that our computers and our
technology,
we're able to translate to digitize and
put it in a form that the human mind can
understand.
So in the same way the human mind,
it's a biocomputer and maybe these
psychedelics create an upgrade to the
operating system that allows a
temporary window into the unknown.
And when you see that and you come
back to this world and talk about it,
people think you're nuts because you
can't take pictures of something that,
uh,
your mind is seeing after it's gone
into a specific state of intoxication.
You can only take
pictures by describing it.
Now also,
if you believe that psychedelics can
rewire the mind to allow us to see the,
uh,
the invisible world that
exists around us at all times,
then maybe people who are a little crazy,
these things poking out from
behind the lattice of reality.
Maybe they do see it in the same way
that when a person who isn't crazy,
for lack of a better word,
take psychedelics.
So in that way,
perhaps the lens of our perception
when it's altered in some way,
whether because you're a little on
the naughty side or because
you've taken some mushrooms,
maybe when that Lens has shifted,
it allows us to see so much more.
Yeah,
that's very possible.
It's very possible that that's exactly
what's happening in this area in Utah as
well,
because this area,
besides having this one spot where
everybody claims all these events are
happening,
you know what else it
has around their cattle,
cattle all over the place.
The guy had a cattle ranch,
this cat,
we drove past several ranches where
this cattle and with his cattle,
this cow shit.
Yep.
And with his cow shit.
In a place where it rains all the time,
there's a party,
there's a party.
You're going to get some magic mushrooms
growing in the cow shit and a if that's
all you're doing,
you're just hanging out in the middle
of nowhere in Utah eating mushrooms,
staring at the rocks,
you're going to see some shit.
Look,
man,
I've told you this story before.
I've eaten my shrimps.
I've been attacked by elves.
I've seen hyper dimensional entities.
I was on mushrooms and I saw it.
I'm not going to go around
saying that Elvis or rail,
but I'll tell you,
when I was laying on that lawn chair
at the spa with Elf swimming through my
body and making fun of my thoughts,
it seemed very real.
And it didn't seem fun at all.
It was an unfunded,
terrifying experience.
And,
um,
if I'd lived 200 years ago and had just
been forging for food and happened to
eat some food and that
had that experience,
I would go back to the village and say,
they're Elvis in the woods there.
Elves,
they swim through your body.
They make fun of your thoughts.
They're magic.
They,
and so I think that,
uh,
psychedelics are a component,
in the sick and the experiences
that people have of this nature.
But I don't think that that
means that the experience that,
I don't think that
invalidates the experience.
Well,
it's also brings into account the
fact that the brain itself produces
psychedelic chemicals.
Yes.
Without any help whatsoever.
The brain produces
dimethyltryptamine five methoxy,
dimethyltryptamine,
dopamine,
serotonin.
There's a lot of shit
going on in that brain.
Melatonin,
your brain is producing all of these
chemicals and they come out and varying
amounts,
just like we have varying dick sizes and
some people have shitty I side and this
guy was born with a bad liver.
Guess what?
Some people also get indogenous dumps
of psychedelic chemicals they can't
control.
And so they start seeing things.
Yes,
and this is something that's
very difficult to measure.
They've just recently figured out how
to measure the pineal gland of rats to
prove that the pineal gland itself
is a source of dimethyltryptamine.
Until really recently
it was just a theory.
So now they know that for sure,
but the way they had to do,
they had to cut open
the head of a live rat.
You know,
you're not going to let up.
No one's going to let a
person do that to them.
So we're not even going to find out what
what's going on inside a person's head.
As far as the consultant,
the production of this stuff.
And we certainly are not gonna be able
to figure out when it's active and when
it's not.
These big rushes in bursts.
Unless we get more
advanced medical equipment or unless
we can get right to the source of it,
cut open someone's brain while
they're in the middle of an activity,
neither one of those
events is very likely.
So you're not going to be able to tell
whether or not someone who had this crazy
experience just had this rush of naturally
produce psychedelic chemicals that we
know exist in the brain.
That's it.
Exactly,
man.
And maybe when they have that rush,
they're actually perceiving something
that is there and some form something that
exists in the same way radio waves exist
in the same way that ultraviolet rays
exist.
And we'll never know that until we stop
the prohibition on psychedelics and
start studying them again.
But that's probably never going to happen.
Um,
the experience was still fun.
You know,
I enjoy going to rural places and the
scenery there was beautiful and uh,
Mike had all those pieces of petrified
wood that he had found in that area.
Apparently.
He said,
it's all over the place.
You just find petrified
wood and it's really,
really super common.
It's just a very,
it's a very strange place.
Like it's a,
it's very beautiful.
And they said there's a
lot of cougars out there.
They see like not the chicks that are
looking for actions are over 40 is not.
That's not what they meant.
They meant like mountain lions,
a lot of mount line activity
and one of the women,
the,
what's her name that took us up there?
Shannon.
Shannon,
right.
That woman Shannon,
while we were walking up
to the top of that bluff,
she told me she heard a cat.
Yes.
She said she just didn't want to upset us.
I go,
how do you know that you heard one?
She goes,
you can tell what they sound like.
but they didn't want to
have anything to do with us,
so I just didn't want to alarm y'all.
Hmm.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
we're heard a mountain line like
right next to us in the bushes.
And she's like,
no.
Where I keep it moving,
keep it moving.
It's only nighttime when they hunt.
You guys have to be
careful with this show,
man.
Yeah.
You're telling me man,
got up and when I send
you to the weird spots,
yeah,
it's bad.
It's dangerous.
Look,
we're up in Cougar country who is
guiding us captain crazy phase.
Yeah.
Were guided through herds
of cougars by a lunatic.
This is afraid of,
what was the bulletproof Wolf Wrangler?
The orb color.
You know the horse whisperer.
He's the Sasquatch whisper.
Either Sasquatch was Burke.
It's,
I think it's,
uh,
if only founding bigfoot
knew about this guy.
You know,
if we knew about this guy and
when we were looking for big foot,
we would've saved a lot of time.
Yup.
To me,
the guy's just a magnet for the stuff.
Bring him out there,
hanging from a tree,
like bait.
But when we're around man,
even,
you know,
even though he's a magnet
for paranormal activity,
when we're around,
we just were such losers that
we just jinxed it for him.
Well,
that's what he thinks.
That's what he thinks probably.
Yeah.
I wonder if he some stuff while
we were all out there together,
but he didn't want to bring it up unless
we brought her up cause he wasn't sure
if it was real.
Do you guys see my grandmother?
No.
Good.
Just checking.
Yeah,
I didn't really,
that's not Abraham Lincoln.
They're telling me that I should
blow up the federal building.
Abraham Lincoln dressed up like the
silver surfer with a swim cap on
the,
uh,
the area was beautiful though.
You know,
it's the,
uh,
the ranch itself when we
were overlooking the ranch.
Gorgeous.
I would love to have a ranch like that.
It looks so bad ass,
you know that a ranch house and
beautiful trees and the beautiful field.
I think that's the real gift that hunting
for the paranormal gives you is it
gets you out in the nature.
Yeah.
It's one beautiful thing about it,
man.
This thing takes recluses out of their
basement and endo nature to you go going
for ghosts.
That one sex.
Yeah,
indoor goes tiny,
but still at least you're driving to
other houses and a lot of people go to
cemeteries and go outside
to look for ghosts.
This is nice man,
because people who otherwise would just
be sitting and moldering piles of old
diapers,
spraying d odor in the air to cover the
stench of rotting cat that died three
weeks ago,
or they stare in the Internet
conspiracy theory websites.
This gets them out into nature and I
think that's a beautiful thing about it.
It is,
and you know what?
In normally in nature,
just wandering around,
they'd probably start getting depressed.
It pros nothing.
What am I doing with my life?
But when you're running for
your life inside of a graveyard,
because you know a ghost is chasing you,
it makes things way more interesting
and way more engineers you a spark of
excitement.
You in fact live the exact same life.
Even if you imagined that this would
be happening if you pretended that this
would be happening and convinced yourself,
you would live the exact same life as if
an actual ghost was really chasing you.
So you're goofy,
shitty brain decides this,
throw some chemicals down the hatch it.
Listen,
this guy's barely hanging on,
let's reward and what a
little of the good stuff.
So they opens up some valve in your brain
and psychedelic chemicals flow and you
know all the sudden your shitty life
that you're like barely hanging on and
really thinking hard about
jumping in front of a train.
Yeah.
All of a sudden it's transformed and like
you are the one who's been haunted by
Richard the eighth from another dimension.
He comes out of the ground with
a fucking Turkey leg in his hand.
He was chasing you around the,
hey,
it's gray.
Why not?
It's better than his real
life is real life sucks.
The fat one.
Yeah man.
Well,
I mean,
right.
This is the eternal problem is do we
embrace the fantasma on the invisible to
make our white,
our lives glow with the light of lies
or do we just deal with the fact that we
exist in an end,
permanent part of the time space
continuum and in a matter of a few
cosmic blinks are atoms are going to go
spraying a part into infinity and we're
going to be worm food.
That's a hard thing for a
lot of people to digest.
So maybe they create these mythologies
to come for them a little bit.
But all that being said,
I think that there's some people who
may be actually have contact with this
stuff just because crazy people
believe it doesn't mean it's not real.
It's like that old saying
just because what does,
how does it go?
Just because you're paranoid doesn't
mean people aren't following you.
Well just cause you're crazy.
It doesn't mean that there's
no big foot out there.
It's true.
So we can't just say because the sources
of all seem to have a burnt antenna,
it doesn't necessarily mean that
the phenomena doesn't exist.
Let me ask you this.
Have you experienced any blow back for
your willingness to engage in any of
these ideas,
whether it's Ufo shows or big foot
or anything spectacular like that?
And I think paranormal and anything out
of the realm of normal everyday life.
Have you experienced
any blow back blowback?
Yeah.
Is there any people like people like
judging you for being a Wacko conspiracy
theorist and talking about Harper,
Kevin trails?
Not at all.
Everybody thinks I'm a very rational,
logical person.
I think a lot of people
think I'm a scientist.
I actually nominated for a Nobel prize.
I believe my research is bulletproof.
No,
I mean I honestly,
I have not gotten very much condescension
because I hang out with you.
I mean,
look man,
I don't get a lot of that judgment,
but um,
I think actually it's
the other way around.
I think you tend to get more judgment
from people when you're a skeptic than you
do if you're a believer.
I think skeptics take a lot of heat,
man.
You know,
I took more heat from the chem trail
episode than anything else I've ever done
on Twitter.
More people were upset at me because they
believe that I'm like contributing to
Geo engineering by the elites at the
global elites are mixing aluminum in the
jet fuel and using it to
control the population like Ooh,
that it's actually Nano particles in
the chem trails that they're heating up
with harp and they using that
to control the population.
Like Golly,
a certain point in time you just go,
wow,
what am I doing?
Even communicating with you fuck heads.
Well,
I love the idea of following
that all the way through.
So this is what I like to imagine as the
meeting where you're in an underground
laboratory surrounded by
federal agents are like,
listen Joe,
I think that they're catching on that
we're spraying aluminum into their
playgrounds.
You're a charismatic guy.
Can you do this?
Show calm everything down a little bit.
What do you want an island?
We'll give you an island,
a mortal life,
and by the way,
look,
I can turn into a lizard
and they send you back into the world
to do a show in the Psi Phi network.
That's their answer to,
to the
problem.
Yeah.
That's how you can show the problem.
You get dirty comedians who also double
as cage fighting commentators and you
have them disseminate the information
because everybody knows they are so
reliable,
accurate with their,
their view of the world.
Well,
it's not like he's fucked up at all.
it's no,
it's not like the guy's
a marijuana advocate.
Hey listen,
we need to convince these conspiracy
theorists that there is an actually Kim
trails gimme that guy with a DMT molecule
tattooed on his arm and the other guy
has got that youtube video
of him projectile vomiting.
Yeah,
man,
it's a grand conspiracy.
You figured this out,
Dick.
Fuck 79 on Twitter.
He's silly bitch.
Yeah,
there's,
there's no getting around the fact
that because of the Internet you get to
communicate with a lot of people
that you wouldn't ordinarily,
there's people that you would gravitate
towards and you find them as well,
but there's also people that somehow or
another show up at the party and you're
like,
Oh God,
what is this?
And you're going to
have to deal with that.
That's part of the whole openness of the
complete experience of the Internet is
that you are going to have to deal
with that part of the part of the pro
blow harder,
the fun man and,
but I again,
that's why I think that you have to hold
people with extraordinary claims even
more to the fire of logic and truth
than other people because it's because
you've got it.
I really believe that there is a,
for lack of a better word,
a supernatural realm.
There is something outside
human perception that is
populated that is possibly
populated with a sentient
beings that aren't embodied.
I think that that's possible.
It's been reported in every religion,
every mythology.
It's a story that keeps coming
up again and again and again.
Everything.
Your own personal experiences.
Yes.
So having had these personal experiences,
it's something that you,
you,
you not only except it yourself,
but you feel compelled to
tell other people about it.
Yes,
and the history of humanity is one where
humans are being led by an invisible
being.
The world religions have
controlled society for a long,
long time.
And these world religions all have
at their root outside of Buddhism,
the notion of an invisible entity
that as an interest in guiding humans.
And so this is not just some
imaginary thing in the sense that,
uh,
that it's something that people
talk about who also huff glue.
This is something that's been controlling
the flow of history for thousands of
years.
So I think that it's very important
to try to get to the truth of it.
What's the core?
Is it just the brain?
Is the brain just some
drug dealer or our brains?
Just a grateful dead parking lot that
from time to time spray hallucinogenics
into us.
The back of the bus explodes and acid
flies through the air like confetti and
everybody just sticks her tongue out.
Yeah.
Is that what it is or is in,
is that all it is?
Is it just that the neurons in our
brain misfire a little bit like a,
like a electrical cable in a puddle
and it causes it to see these entities?
Or is there another universe that exists
that we can see if we learn to control
our minds and our consciousness and I
think it's important to explore those
ideas.
I think also that our life in
this dimension of conscious
reality is filled with
so much uncertainty and so much confusion
and we have such a inclination to
follow others,
to follow smarter people than us to
follow the leader too because we're all
basically terrified of what we're doing.
We're all going through life be barely
hanging on because you don't really want
to think about the entirety of
it all because it's too much.
I just got to get to the
work by x time and you know,
I punch out at six and then
I'm going to go do this.
Like that's,
that's filling your time and it's not
by any small coincidence that that's
filling your time.
It's because if the,
if it wasn't,
if you really were spending all of
your time contemplating your existence,
it would almost be overwhelming.
It would almost be too much for
you to wrap your head around.
And because of that,
we seek to defined our
universe in very certain terms.
This is real.
That's nonsense.
This,
this is would,
you know,
there's no elves in space around me.
You don't know what you're talking.
And we were like adamant about our,
our version of reality to the point where
people get upset at you if you want to
escape this version of reality.
Oh,
you looking for a way out.
Are you scared?
A reality?
You can't handle reality.
You've got to take drugs.
Like people will say that to me
and what are they trying to do?
They're terrified of other
people escaping reality too.
They're terrified of reality.
They're terrified of different definitions
that they have could have to consider
of reality.
Everyone is,
it's not something we address,
but it is subconscious.
It is there all the time.
Yup.
It's true,
man.
And,
and I,
and I think that the impulse
behind skeptics is of,
is a,
is a great impulse.
It's an impulse that changes
the world for the better.
When I don't,
I don't know who,
uh,
was the first person to say that there
are diseases were called caused by germs.
I wish I did.
But,
um,
if that person who
started figuring out that,
oh,
I think there's invisible entities that
crawl into our body and make us sick.
If that person hadn't explored
that in a scientific way,
then who knows what could
have happened to humanity.
You know,
we all the,
all the different cures and
antibiotics that we have,
that wouldn't have happened.
I mean eventually it would have happened.
But if somebody,
you had that initial impulse,
I think there's invisible creatures that
get as sick when they started saying
that everyone around them
where they thought they,
they were insane.
You know,
the story of the,
um,
uh,
I can't remember the name as a doctor
who ended up in an insane asylum,
but cause he started suggesting that
doctors wash their hands before they
deliver babies.
He would say if you're touching a corpse,
wash your hands and then deliver the baby.
And doctors at the time said,
gentlemen,
have no need to wash their hands because
they didn't know that there was viruses
and bacteria,
uh,
existing in the world because
it hadn't been proven.
So this guy who came up with this
idea that doctors or wash their hands,
he ended up in a mental asylum.
He went crazy because
he knew this was real.
He went insane because he knew that there
was something called germs and nobody
believed in it at the time.
So that's the,
that's the great problem.
All the people out there
bugling about Ufos,
bugling about,
uh,
wormholes and big foot and missed wolf's.
They have to let skeptics interrogate
them in the most intense way,
not to disprove them or
show that they're crazy,
but to get to the core truth.
And sometimes the core
truth is just theirs.
They're the only one who were
really have access to it.
And if it was some sort of a hallucination
or whether it was real to them,
but we can't perceive it because we
weren't tuned into whatever frequency and
radio dial of the universe that they
were at the time that it happened.
The bottom line is you got to bring
something back in order for me to take it
totally seriously.
I'm listening.
I'll listen.
I'll try to put myself in your footsteps.
I'll try to put my myself in your head
and try to figure out what you possibly
could have been experiencing,
why it was all going down,
but unless it's happening to me,
it's all just nonsense.
You know,
and that's,
that's a a real part of the reality
that these folks are experiencing and it
should be.
It has to be,
you know,
less.
I can experience it myself.
There's nothing that I've seen
that compels me to believe anybody.
This is nothing I've seen that compels
me that this is an actual UFO landing
side,
that this is a guy who's
been a board of space ship,
that this is someone who's been abducted.
Apparently there's some people that tell
me that they're going to tell me the
story of what happened to them
and I'm going to believe it.
And you're going to meet one of them.
You're going to meet this woman named
Nicole Dome and you're going to sit down
with her.
And she apparently has some sort of an
alien implant that she claims she got
inside of her body.
I don't know the full story,
but a,
you're going to learn it and uh,
I figured it'd be perfect for you.
That's your type of person.
Yeah.
This sounds like an eharmony date for me.
Freaky tattooed up.
Very pretty girl who's
been abducted by aliens.
It's my cell mate.
That's it.
You're on your other path is exciting.
I've never met a person that
has been abducted by aliens.
I'm at a couple of people that told
me they were abducted by aliens,
but I'm pretty sure
they were bullshitting.
Like I've never met one person
who had a story that I was like,
wow,
that this,
this um,
this seems to be real.
Um,
but I'm told that,
uh,
there's a woman,
her name is Nicole and
you're gonna meet her.
And this woman apparently
has an incredibly believable,
compelling story.
And people that have
talked to her have said,
you know,
wow.
Like you walk away from it and you go,
I believe her.
I don't know.
And I,
but I trust your judgment and uh,
it's,
she's right up your alley.
She's really hot.
Freaky look in covered in tattoos and uh,
she's been a borders Ufo.
So mean.
This is my soulmate.
Your soulmate.
That's amazing.
So go meet her and talk
to her and you know,
tell us what's up.
I'm there.
E harmony date.
Okay.
Tell me about Nicole dome.
Wow,
you're right.
She's a beautiful woman.
Uh,
tattoos,
interesting tattoos.
Um,
she seemed very grounded,
focused.
Uh,
she did not seem anything
like captain crazy cake from,
what did you call him?
Captain crazy phase.
He,
she sees,
she didn't seem anything
like captain crazy face.
She was very focused,
calm,
open.
She definitely experienced something.
Okay.
What was her story?
She's leaving a diner with her friend.
They want to go play pool.
It's late at night.
This is a small town.
She's driving down the road and
suddenly they witnessed this hexagon,
a light above the car.
And so she,
they decided to pull over to look at
the light because they're experiencing a
Ufo and suddenly she's
driving down the road.
Yeah.
And she's a mile down the road and,
uh,
she gets to meet her friends at the
pool hall and they're pissed off because
she's an hour late and she should have
been there in four minutes after leaving
the cafe.
So she had the type of,
uh,
the,
what do they call that?
The tip not aggression sheet now.
And I am not a progression.
She had at time loss,
she had time loss.
Uh,
and she and her friends seemed
drugged after the experience.
So that's,
that's her experience.
Her friends seemed drugs.
Yes.
When they were driving down the road
after having decided to stop to look at
this light,
there are further down the road
with no memory of what's happened.
They have the typical form of
Amnesia that abductees talk about.
Her friends seems like she's drugged.
Her friends seem like she's been
anesthetized or given some kind of drug to
knock her out.
They both,
she's our friends groggy.
I asked if they,
if a friend was drunk
or did they were high?
She said No.
And where were they coming from?
They were from a diner.
Is it possible that someone
dosed them in the diner?
Absolutely.
Right.
It is possible that they were seen as
much more likely someone was being an
asshole who's a working in the kitchen,
decide to slip some LSD into their
cheerio's or whatever the hell they ate,
haven't seen as much more likely.
Well,
she,
yes,
definitely.
That's a possibility.
Now,
uh,
her story is not that she ended up in
somebody's basement tied to a chair on
Cheerio laden LSD or
Lsd Laden cheerio's she,
her story is that,
um,
psychics started telling her that
something on the left side of her body was
off.
And this happened a couple of times.
Uh,
and so she went to a UFO convention.
And
Are you looking at me like,
well,
because here's,
here's my feeling.
You know how I feel about psych techs
and I think you know how I feel about
people that find out something
really special happened to them.
All those things are very suspect.
The psychic thing is
incredibly suspect to also,
a lot of people are very susceptible to
suggestion and a lot of people are very
susceptible to attractive
girls with tattoos.
That's,
you know.
Yeah,
so I knew you were going to have
a problem with reality here,
whereas if she was a fat guy with three
teeth and she smelled like Heineken,
you,
you'd feel like this guy's an asshole.
He wasn't a border Ufo.
He's trying to get me to look at it.
Stomach man.
It was gross.
He kept lifting up his beer gut asking
me if I had a black light and I'm like,
this guy's going to try to fuck me.
I got gotta.
Get out of here.
That's what you would've said.
You were hypnotized by the sweet nectar
of youth and the reckless indignation of
a girl with tattoos on her tits.
That's what happened with you.
You got caught up in the the tsunami.
That is the sexuality of that woman.
And you were willing to loan,
Oh yeah,
you want to Skype,
I can see your implants.
I mean,
you know the alien one,
right?
It's natural.
That's why you know,
I mean it's empire for
some people it's very know
I'm not gonna argue with you the,
the vehicle telling the UFO story.
If it is a,
if it happens to be a beautiful young,
tattooed girl,
then yes.
I,
you know what,
my ears are going to perk
up a little bit more.
But I will say that I've run into a lot
of pretty tattoo girls who seem bat shit
crazy.
They seem like they've
been staring at the sun,
isn't it?
And Glue who,
you know,
it's just cause you're right.
So I will say that and you can
review the tape.
I will say that she seemed very centered,
focused her,
she believed her story.
And um,
the most compelling evidence that she
has is that apparently there is a scar on
her stomach and that if
you put a black light over,
you can see it.
It wasn't there when she
showed it to us at the bar.
The problem issues getting this
information from a psychic.
The problem is she's
getting this information,
not just from a sidekick,
but someone who says they're a psychic
and almost everyone who says they're a
psychic is full of shit.
It might be 100% of them,
but it's at least 90 dine.
Okay.
So the odds of her finding the one out
of a hundred that isn't full of shit,
those odds really suck.
So then you have a person
who is a nice person,
but a person willing to
get tattoos on their tits.
Okay,
she's gay,
she's gangster.
She's willing to take some chances.
Look,
I have tattoos myself.
She's willing to take some chances.
Okay.
She's wild.
She's willing to go with it.
Yeah,
we'll want to go with an idea and she
might be willing to go with a memory
that's some crazy fucking fake
psychic plants in her brain.
And it sounds real.
And when you convince
yourself a shit like that,
if you're so inclined,
especially,
and I believe she probably is so inclined
to believe the fantastic common for
people who have UFO abduction experiences
to have like an inclination towards
that type of thing.
They believe in that type of thing,
which aids the experience confirmation
bias and she's only talking about
memories.
That's right.
Well here's the provable part.
She has going,
apparently these beings abducted or the
memories that she has are of being put
on a steel table and they
did something to our ovaries,
possibly put an implant inside of her.
She's actually going to get tests within
the next few days to see what's going
on down there and to see if there is some
kind of implant there and also it's an
Iud.
She forgot about,
she had an IUD put in when she
was in high school and it's just,
Oh fuck.
Where'd that thing go?
I look,
I hear is that
she has no,
she has no evidence right now to prove.
Of course it doesn't have any evidence,
but she's going to get it and
she's not going to happen.
She's not going to happen.
How about that?
How about hold your breath.
It's never going to appear.
There's going to be no evidence.
It doesn't exist.
You're never going to find it.
It lives inside the imagination only.
I'm going to scan her with a blacklight.
It might be a real experience now.
Okay.
As far as memories go,
her memory might be as real as my memories
of some stuff I did just a couple of
weeks ago,
which are very shady at best.
If you asked me about my trip to the
mall to get my laptop fixed two weeks ago
and I had to recount
everything that happened.
If you could see inside my memory about
how shitty it really is and little,
I really remember about
my trip to the mall.
I remember almost nothing.
If you told me I had to pick out
where I was parked or there was,
I couldn't drive home and black shit.
I Dunno where I parked.
I have no idea where I parked at the mall
two weeks ago and that was me and that
was real while I was awake.
So these memories of this woman has
that are pulled out of a dream state.
Okay.
Pulls out of a hypnotic state.
Suggested to her by a psychic.
Don't they don't even live
in her conscious memory.
A memory that she's piecing together from
something that someone told her about
some dreams maybe.
Yeah,
that might as well me
and my trip to the mall.
Okay.
Cause so it to her it is real.
So when she's telling you that it's real,
she does feel it's real.
And when she looks down,
first of all,
why is this freak looking at
herself with black lights?
Well that's,
this lever looks at
themselves with a black light.
He was at a UFO convention.
Naked.
No liquor.
Your belly button.
No,
this is the story for Real UFO convention,
which shows up under black light loads.
They do,
they show up like ghosts.
This is a cut.
They take you to take your little woman
and have a little party on her upper mid
section and then then flash if a black
light close the shut the lights off,
close the shades,
use a black light.
You like,
oh,
now I get it.
Yeah,
that's a scar,
honey.
She got caught with a gun shot of load.
That's what it is.
She got caught in the crossfire and
some of it was still stuck on her side.
Can you please not talk about Nicole?
I'm sorry.
It wasn't even really Nicole.
I'd never met her.
She said to me,
she's an imaginary person,
but I need to tell you where the black
light thing happened because then you can
really start making fun of her.
Okay.
The how,
so how did she find out about this car?
She found out about the
scar at a UFO convention.
She said that there was a booth where
someone had written in black sharpie scans
for alien implants and you go into the
booth and they make you take your clothes
off and they run a blacklight
over your body and they tell you,
they tell you if you have an implant and
life is beautiful.
It's really beautiful.
Life is a beautiful thing
because it's a play.
It's,
it's,
we're watching it all play out.
It's really a grand piece of artwork
that's constructed for our amusement.
There's no other way.
There's no other way that could be real.
There's no other way that someone could
have a booth at a Ufo conference where
you have to take your clothes off and
they'd look at you with a black light,
which oh,
just so happens to show
loads all the loads on you,
all the loads on you glow like one of
those panther paintings that you had in
high school.
I remember those black
light posters that you had.
The panther had like yellow teeth and
claws and yellow eyes and little little
red with his mouth.
Maybe truck dealer had won.
Those were the shit.
That's what they're looking for.
The idea is so
that that's how she found out about this,
that it really feels like we're in
the middle of a Coen brothers movie.
This,
this is that.
This is a real person and this is
really happening in today in 2013 in the
modern era of smartphones pressing Google,
asking it where to go.
It gives you directions in this world.
Someone finds themselves naked with
a black light going over their body,
while some white guy with dreadlocks is
telling them about scars that they got
because they were picked up by aliens.
She said,
the guy worked at NASA.
I'm Fuzzy Dick.
He's a cleanup guy,
cleans up the spoon.
He said,
NASA cleanup booth guy.
They have a devotee of peep booth at NASA.
It's very well it's,
you know,
a lot of those astronauts is
through a very stressful job.
They need to unwind.
They like peep booths.
This guy,
he's the official mopper well
shows live with a black light at parties.
He keeps everything rocking.
This fucking guy's got
his own black light.
Jesus Christ.
Glow sticks to the dickhead.
I agree,
man.
It's what you believe.
This woman,
I believe this is the part
that's going to get on TV.
See,
these are real podcasts
now you know your Fox,
okay?
I believe that she experienced some
believe that she's hot and hypnotic.
Let's start with that.
She's hot.
She's hypnotic in you and I both know
that you've always had a thing for
tattooed up girls,
especially girls with good work.
Let's be honest,
who doesn't?
That's a dangerous woman,
willing to take chances,
and if you're a standup comedians,
that's the type of person
you need in your life.
Right.
Okay.
That's all.
She's gangster.
Yes.
Okay,
so you liked that,
right?
Yeah,
me too.
All right,
go ahead.
So you're infatuated.
You're intoxicated.
This beautiful woman,
God,
you're so close to it.
You could smell her and she's
showing you her little scars.
Oh,
wow.
Yeah,
I can totally see it.
Yeah.
You get a black light and
you know we can look cool.
Next thing you know,
she's wearing your fedora.
You're both naked.
You still got your socks off,
black lights going back and forth
in a dressing room somewhere.
Yes.
Yeah,
easily.
Man,
I can see it.
Okay.
You're not really going to give me an
accurate assessment of what really went
down.
I wouldn't.
I need to be there with you.
I need to be there with you
to watch your chemical makeup,
to watch your body shift
like a giant human mood ring.
All of a sudden you just green
with horniness as you're glowing,
like the whole,
if you were a mood ring,
it would start cracking at the seams,
would be able to take
the g force of green.
It's pumping into the size of
this poor fucking mood ring.
Here's the thing,
like a big
aquarium trying to hold in sharks
explodes and takes your finger
off with it just because,
okay,
so just cause a pretty girl is talking
about aliens doesn't mean that a person
showing you were skin
lifting up her clothes.
She's going like this.
Sorry.
That's about seven inches
from my been saying.
If you went from my pussy
up with your fingers,
you would,
it'd be like seven inches.
Look man,
all of what you're saying is accurate.
It's not.
It doesn't mean she wasn't abducted.
Exactly.
It's like you said earlier,
just because you're paranoid
doesn't mean enough following.
Yes.
Just cause you're a beautiful,
tattooed girl with an invisible scar
doesn't mean that you didn't get abducted
by aliens.
Just because you're a crazy liar.
It doesn't mean you haven't
really been a board of Ufo.
That's right.
That's exactly right.
So,
you know,
that's why I'm looking forward to
getting the results of her tasks.
You guys going to stay in touch?
Can I send her an email?
You're not going to
believe this is the bid.
They just came out with a new type of
black light that works best on naked
girls.
It's amazing.
I,
I'm an Amazon prime member and it's uh,
it's already here.
It's here.
Like you could come over
and try it if you want.
I mean,
I'm totally cool with it.
Oh,
it is dark out.
She has a boyfriend.
Okay.
Just these are just jokes folks.
We don't mean anything.
We're saying not at all.
Okay.
But what I am saying is that I'm not
entirely sure that you were the hard nose
private.
I would have liked on the case.
No Way,
man.
No Way.
You're not going to get an ambush me.
And that's a course.
Not of course not God,
man.
Hey Man.
Even if it was a charismatic man,
okay.
I have often wondered if Tom Cruise
is trying to convince me of something.
I've seen Tom Cruise give interviews.
He's incredibly convincing.
Okay.
I've seen Tom cruise argue with people
about stuff you don't want to be in an
argument with Tom Cruise now and if
Tom Cruise is telling you about his UFO
abduction,
you might,
you might be inclined to believe it,
man might be inclined to believe it.
He might be so charismatic that he can
just hit every note exactly the right way
with the right amount of pause,
the right amount of
sincere emotional content.
You know,
man,
I have no proof of this.
And I'd say if this goes on the show,
you're all getting a huge lawsuit.
But I heard that Tom Cruise pays guys to
come into his gym when he's working on
rape him.
Let's edit that out.
Um,
okay.
All right.
We wrapped up Nicole dumb
start with,
okay.
Okay.
So what were your impressions of Nicole?
She was a very focused
and you go to start by that time,
there's more.
Yeah.
For more information about this
much for this conversation,
you're not going to get all of it.
Okay.
Sorry.
It's [inaudible] dot
com they're not gonna,
they're not gonna show all this shit.
But for more information,
go to [inaudible] dot com we
have a lot more of this up there.
We had to edit this.
It's a 44 minute shelf up.
Um,
okay.
And then can it be said
what?
It's all right to say it.
The camera again.
I think that's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It doesn't matter what,
that might be funny as like as each other,
what would happen if you got abducted,
but you got to each of
you and that was okay.
We're good.
Um,
what do you think would happen?
We good.
We good?
Yep.
Okay.
Have you ever saw it about what
you would do if you were abducted?
What do you think would happen?
I'd cry and scream and try to keep
whatever I could out of my asshole.
Would you or would you worry that if you
didn't give up they would just paralyze
you and,
and do horrible things to you?
Maybe,
maybe even kill you?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think that that is what happens
is they end up paralyzing you.
Do you think that people
have ever been killed by you?
LFOS
yeah,
I don't think so.
I don't know man.
I mean it killed by you,
fos.
No,
no.
I don't think people,
men killed by your foes,
but plenty of people say that they've
gotten sucked up onto these ships and some
people think that it's,
you have,
as some people say,
it could just be government agents.
By the way,
if you're a,
here's the thing,
if you're an inventor,
but you're also a Perv,
all you have to do is have a levitating
craft that can suck people into that.
They're totally cool with getting caught
as we still ahead of the curve though.
And the fun that thing,
you'd have to sell it.
You'd have to sell them to fund it and
then it would go public and then it would
get out and then people would be careful.
They would wear special tinfoil hats,
doesn't allow them to get sucked
into your giant rape ship.
People talk about it.
If you get sucked up into
a UFO and you get probed,
as they call it,
people talk about it.
No,
he went to essentially violating
experience taken into some guy's trailer.
Like if that happened to you or you're
just walking down the street and somehow
you got hypnotized by like a spiral in
a trailer park and you ended up getting
like probed by some redneck dude wanted
to shove his water bong inside of you,
you wouldn't talk about that.
That's not a story you share.
But somehow if you get taken up into a
silver trailer in space and get probed by
a thing,
it's like,
hey,
I got probed.
Well it's always a medical experiment
was never sexual in nature.
Never left purposely.
So aliens are creeps.
So if you were abducted,
but are they whose creepier and the alien
or the zookeeper?
The alien.
Why?
Because they do it to people.
How about the guy who works at seaworld
tells dolphins they have to flip or they
don't get fish who's creepier?
I'd say the aliens are less creepy
cause they seem to leave us in the wild.
They don't seem to keep us.
They don't seem to be like kidnapping
people left and right and sucking them up
in a giant space.
Zoos,
I say the aliens are less
creepy than the zookeeper.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
If I told you that I drew,
drove around in my car and from time to
time picked up stray dogs and shoved my
fingers,
they're assholes
and then put them back out in the street.
What'd you think?
I was creepy.
I look,
I love you man.
So I'm not the best person to judge.
I'd forgive you.
I say he's probably shouldn't do that,
man.
It's probably bad Karma,
but it's not like I would rat
you out for something like that.
Friends Dude.
But I think that,
I mean,
I don't know that,
like I said,
I don't know anyone who,
I legitimately believe their
alien abduction experience,
so I don't know what's happening.
I don't know if it is just in fact a
memory that someone has introduced into
their mind and they relay
it as if it was a fact,
but much like my real memories,
they're very sketchy.
I've had some beautiful moments in my
life and I look back on them and there's
duff flashes and trying to
try to piece it together,
you know,
try to piece together some of the
most memorable spec tack rule events,
spectacular events in your life.
And they still,
they come off like weird slideshows of
blurry images and a narrative that you
can follow in your head because
you know it cause you remember it.
And also because you've
said it a bunch of times,
you told people about the experience,
but the reality of your memories,
there's terrible.
So it's,
it's so hard to say what
exactly is going on.
Well,
you know what those gray aliens look like,
right?
They look like,
and I think someone else
has posited this theory,
but if you look at the gray
aliens and you take a doctor with,
um,
with a,
medical mask on and you look
at him delivering a baby,
the first thing a lot
of people see is this,
that kind of shape,
that kind of thing.
And when you're taken out of the womb and
suddenly they're running medical tests
on you,
which is what happens when you're born.
They weigh you,
they do all this weird shit to you.
I don't know exactly what then that is
a very traumatic experience and some
people say that alien of dod teas are
actually reliving the trauma of birth.
That's what they're experiencing is the
trauma of being yanked out of a very
warm,
safe place and being poked and prodded
by beings that you can't possibly
understand because you've never seen
another human being in your life.
Totally makes sense.
And then also it sort of makes sense why
there's such a clinical nature to all
these experiences and it's always these
cold tables and it pokes and no one's
talking.
You know,
one's loving and warm and comforting.
It's always just medical and cold and
sanitary and and very dark and bleak.
And the room seems
impossibly large and bright.
Yes,
that's exactly what it is.
It's probably just an implanted memory
that's distorted radically over the years
and added to with dreams and all
sorts of other paranoia's that you,
you gather up and stew together over
the course of a lifetime and then while
you're sleeping and they
all come boiling together,
taking me away.
Meanwhile,
you're just a baby.
Yeah.
You're just a little baby shitting all
over yourself screaming for the first
time,
staring at a fluorescent life.
When you've been inside of a
pussy for the last nine months,
you don't have a fucking clue
as to what you're seeing now.
You,
how would you not remember that?
There was a big question,
but why would we assume that
kids don't remember that?
Some people say he tried to block it
out of your memory because it's so
traumatic.
Horrible thing.
Especially if you get circumcised spraying
out of that thing and they snipped
the tip of your cock off.
Exactly.
And how about if it's done in north docs,
Jewish way where the oil
has to suck on it stuff.
The bleeding.
I tried to forget it.
Yeah,
the hell are you gonna remember that.
You don't want to,
I don't even want to think about
it happening to other people.
Well,
you answered my question for me about
how I feel about being abducted.
I was going to turn the
same question to myself.
What would you do exactly?
Try to stop something from going to my,
but that's it.
It's what you do switch to do because
it probably doesn't really happen.
You know what?
I don't think it really happens
and if it does really happen,
I don't think it happens physically.
I might be wrong,
but I don't think it happens.
Just not enough.
No,
no videos.
It's not a single like security video of
a guy like leaving his body and flying
through the walls and aliens come and
taking them away and the wife Getting Up
to pee in the middle of the
night and the husband's gone.
She calls nine one one and 10 minutes
later he just appears magically underneath
the covers.
There's no,
there's none of that roof.
There's no video.
There's no nothing because
a bunch of weird people.
They're telling weird stories
and that's all you get.
And that's all you're
going to get bank on it.
Put it all in the bank.
Bet It all on black.
You don't have a fucking chance.
No one's pulling anything back.
No one's going to get a picture.
No one's going to have an
implant that's worth a shit.
No one's going to have a single photograph
that doesn't look like bullshit.
No one,
there'll be nothing.
There'll be no evidence until there is,
there'll be no evidence.
I think that we never get to that point.
How about that?
I think human beings get lodged into a
simulation long before we ever figured
out how to really live this planet and I
think that probably happens exactly the
same all throughout the universe.
I bet the only space travel that
people do is inside of simulations.
I bet no one ever gets past it
or that this is what life does.
Life creates an artificial reality.
As soon as it knows how
to and jumps in there,
they create an artificial version of what
they would like when they figured out
that the the human synapse,
is it just a bunch of ones and
zeros and boil it down and copy
it and duplicate it.
I think they just,
that's what we do.
No one ever gets anywhere.
It's a,
well,
I mean it's so much more economical too,
and it just,
it is,
I mean,
it's easier to go into the depths of your
mind than it is to build some kind of
ship and go flying to a dead planet.
Look at dirt.
Look,
I could be wrong,
but I don't think anybody
ever goes anywhere.
I could be wrong,
but I don't think any of these
abductors I've ever left their bed.
I don't think that anybody that's
telling you these stories has ever really
experienced anything in a physical sense.
It doesn't mean it didn't really happen,
but I think that if you could put a
camera over them while they slept and when
they woke up in the morning
with this fantastic story,
but you wouldn't see nothing.
I'm afraid that you may be right.
It could just be a subjective experience.
It could be some kind of traumatic memory.
It could be a lot of things that
are in the subconscious mind,
but one thing's for certain.
A lot of people have had this
experience now why they're having it,
who knows?
But yeah,
you would think with the number of
people are having this experience,
you drive down the road and look to the
side and see people getting sucked up
into the sky and clouds coming back
down confused and people have things,
they have seen things and you
just don't know the stories.
You know?
You're sitting here all smug.
But if it happened to you,
man,
imagine.
Imagine if it happened to you and no one
wants to believe your story and you're
worried about telling people at work.
They might think you're crazy and you
lose your job and you can't feed your
family.
Right?
You can't Cay Brown because
you're sitting here all smug.
Must be nice.
Must be nice to be a standup
comedian living in Los Angeles.
I'm in a trailer park in Oklahoma.
Someone's suck me out of the sky and now
I can't tell my boss the coal mine or I
might lose my fucking kids.
My wife's doing meth,
my fucking tire's flat.
I okay,
you're kind of an asshole Dunkin.
You know that old you talking a lot of
shit about people that have actually had
unique experiences.
Sorry about don't know my life.
Dunkin,
you don't know what I have.
What happened to me that
night changed me forever.
Yeah,
I bet
you're like the old worst.
If they got take him.
The aliens are when
they have duct that guy,
oh God.
Or He's playing golf drunk in the middle
of the night and they scoop him up,
put him back loop.
You guys are dicks.
Okay?
If I was super fucking advanced,
who wouldn't just be stealing people?
Why they play golf,
spit in their face and
shit dealing with this guy.
But that's that.
You know,
that is one thing man,
that like,
uh,
what do you know?
What if you could just like
overpower the aliens like you get,
you never hear about people getting
abducted and then wrestling the aliens to
the ground.
These are apparently
these frail little beings.
What if you could fight them?
I think that the idea is that they've
reached this point where they control
matter what their mind.
That's why they have these giant heads
that are way bigger than ours and that's
why they don't seem to
talk with their mouths.
Yeah,
look at me.
I'm like adding to the folklore.
I'm just making shit up.
I don't know if any of this
has ever happened ever,
but I'm like cool.
Culminating a bunch of
different idiot stories.
Well they communicate with their mind.
They do Dunkin,
what they do.
So basically in plant ideas in your brain,
by the way,
JPL,
you mentioned gps.
You know where that comes from,
right?
That's John Parsons Laboratory.
You know John Parsons was right.
John Parsons was it that the rifle man,
John Parsons is the Devonian
Allister car par salads.
Parsons Parsons was a devotee of Alistair
Crawley who that's his laboratory.
So that Parsons,
he believed in extra dimensional entities
and he would say prayers before he did
any of his tasks with
rocket fuel and stuff.
And,
uh,
l Ron Hubbard,
the founder of Scientology,
stole his girlfriend because
they used to hang out.
You can look that stuff up.
It's all 100% true.
There's a crater on the
moon named after him.
Now,
Alister Crawley,
he wants,
tried to summon the entity.
This is way before people were talking
about aliens and the drawing that he drew
of the entity looks exactly
like the gray aliens.
You can look that up
exactly like a gray alien.
So follow that weird Mays.
Ooh,
maybe it's Jack Parsons.
I can't remember which
Parsons does the rabbit hole.
Sun.
That's the right at all.
We're done.
Anything else?
We good?